in perspectives we've been looking back
at the careers of well-known political
figures we conclude with a look at
lyndon b johnson senate years historian
Robert Caro won a Pulitzer Prize for his
book master of the Senate the third
volume in his biography of LBJ mr. Cairo
spoke about Johnson's colorful career at
the Library of Congress in May
good evening welcome to the Library of
Congress I'm John Cole the director of
the Center for the book in the Library
of Congress the sponsor of tonight's
event our Center for the book was
established a quarter of a century ago
to stimulate public interest in books
and reading we promote books and reading
through a network of state affiliates
covering every state in the Union plus
the District of Columbia and through
projects and programs at the Library of
Congress such as tonight's talk the best
way to keep up with the center for the
book and with our schedule of
forthcoming events is through our
website which is loc.gov e / CF book
which is written on some of the
brochures that you can pick up as you go
out tonight dr. James Billington is the
13th librarian of Congress in our 203
year history he was nominated by
President Ronald Reagan and confirmed by
the US Senate in 1987 it is my pleasure
to present dr. Billington who will
introduce our speaker
thank you very much Robert Caro is a
very special author and I'm happy to say
a special friend of the Library of
Congress in 1983 he was one of 30
biographers who participated in the
center for the book symposium on the art
of biography just then the first volume
of his biography of President Lyndon
Johnson had been published a little more
than a decade later he was a speaker at
another center of the book symposium the
historical novel a celebration of Herman
Wouk by then the second volume of his
biography of President Johnson had been
published and here we are tonight three
events and three Johnson volumes
published I hope you'll let us know as
soon as you can about the publication
date for vol 4 so we can make our plans
accordingly but these as you will be
well aware or not volumes that are
produced overnight he he will be back in
Washington we hope well ahead of vol 4
he will for instance be a headline
speaker in October at the 3rd National
Book Festival which we organized here at
the Library of Congress which is hosted
by by first lady barbara Bush it's a
national celebration of the joy and
importance of books and reading it will
be held this year on the mall on October
4th Robert Caro I've got a long list of
awards and prizes and I think I will run
through some of them because it's a
healthy sign that really deep hard
scholarship that goes on for quite some
time and takes up some length
occasionally is properly rewarded and
recognized his first book the power
broker Robert Moses in the fall of New
York in 1974 to create this book he
spent seven years tracing and talking
with hundreds of men and women who had
worked with for or against Robert Moses
and examining mountains of files never
before open to the public the
powerbroker won both the fuel at
surprise for biography and the Francis
Parkman prize the Society of American
Historians Modern Library named it one
of the
greatest non-fiction books of the 20th
century for the research on his
biography of Lyndon Johnson Caro and his
wife ena move from the from New York
City to the Texas Hill Country and then
to Washington DC to live in the locales
where Johnson grew up and in which he
built while still young his first
political machines Carroll has spent
years examining documents in the Johnson
Presidential Library in Austin
interviewing men and women connected
with Johnson's political life many of
whom had never before been interviewed
first volume of his Johnson worked the
path to power won the National Book
Critics Circle Award its best
non-fiction work of 82 a second volume
means of ascent won the National Book
Critics Circle Award for 1990 and
researching the third volume master of
the Senate Cairo immersed himself in the
world of the United States Senate
spending weeks in the gallery committee
rooms and in Senate offices interviewing
hundreds of people from pages and
kirtland Kirk coatroom clerks to two
senators master of the Senate won the
Los Angeles Times Book Award the 2002
National Book Award for nonfiction in
the 2003 peel and surprise for biography
among the numerous other awards Carroll
has won are the HL Mencken award the car
Pete Collins award from the Texas
Institute of Letters the award and
literature from the American Academy and
Institute Arts and Letters he's a
graduate of Princeton University for six
years he was an award-winning
investigative reporter for Newsday was
also a Nieman Fellow at Harvard
University at the Library of Congress
1985 Herman Wouk symposium Robert Caro
paid tribute to his friends majesty
majestic and noble purpose in portraying
through his World War two novels an
entire world in crisis I think you will
find that the same kind of words are
fully merited and should be amply
bestowed on mr. Carroll so it's my
pleasure to present to all of us a
superb chronicler interpreter of 20th
century America a real historian a real
chronicler of our national life
and one of its most penetrating analysts
of one of its least well covered
subjects by history the Congress of the
United States so here he is ladies and
gentlemen Robert Carroll
thank you well when you mentioned Jim
that I spoke here in 1983 I remember I
spoke started them by talking about how
nervous I was about speaking in public
since then I've spoken in public a lot
but I still feel the same way I'll tell
the same story I'm still so much happier
and more comfortable in my desk and my
typewriter than I am up here at a
lectern that I still feel like the young
rabbi Jewish like me who's just
graduated from rabbinical school and
he's assigned as his first assignment to
be the assistant rabbi of a large
metropolitan congregation and after
about a month the senior rabbi says to
him you know next Friday night you're
going to give you a first sermon the
young rabbi says well I get very nervous
when I speak in public do you have any
advice for me and the older rabbi says
well you know you're allowed to have a
water glass up there on the pulpit with
you and I find it helps if I fill it
with a very dry martini so so the young
rabbi takes the advice and he gives the
sermon and as soon as he does he's done
he hurries to the back of the synagogue
and he says to the older rabbi how do I
do the older of us as well have three
continents to make first of all when I
told you you could have a water glass up
there on the pulpit in front of the
entire congregation and fill it with a
martini I didn't mean you should leave
the olives in it he said second I
suggested that you sipped the martini at
crucial points in me sermon not drink
the entire thing in one huge gulp at the
beginning and third David slew Goliath
he didn't beat the [ __ ] out of
but in having said that having said that
this to look this evening is when I'm
really happy to give and I'll tell you
why because in just thinking that we're
right across from the Capitol and the
Senate of course and I am trying to
decide what to talk about I started
thinking back over moments in the 12
years I've been working on this book
that I had forgotten that I was really
glad that I remembered and one of the
things that I had forgotten and it's
what I'm going to talk about tonight is
the moment at which the years of Lyndon
Johnson depart on the Senate got longer
and longer until I realized that the
whole thing would have to be 4 volumes
instead of 3 you know I when Winston
Churchill was asked how he was coming on
his biography of his great ancestor Lord
Marlborough he said I'm working on the
4th of a projected three volumes well
not to equate myself with Winston
Churchill but I'm in the same boat what
I'm going to talk about tonight is how I
got there from the beginning of my work
on Lyndon Johnson of course I always
knew that the section dealing with
Johnson's twelve years in the United
States Senate January 1949 when he was
sworn in till the end of 1960 the
beginning of 1961 when he left to become
vice president I always knew that the
section dealing with those twelve years
would be not only about Lyndon Johnson
but would also be a study of legislative
power all my books are really about
political power I was never interested
in writing biographies just to tell the
story of the life of the famous man I
never had the slightest interest in
doing that from the first time when I
was a reporter and I thought of doing a
biography of Robert Moses I thought of
biography as a means of illuminating the
great forces illuminating through the
life of the man I wrote about the great
forces that shaped his times and
particularly the force that is political
power because in a political in a
democracy political power shapes all our
lives and I
think that the more we can find out and
learn about it the better our country
will be to do that you have to pick the
right guy of course I picked Robert
Moses because we're taught in a
democracy ultimate power comes from a
ballot box from being elected
well Robert Moses was never elected to
anything yet he had more power than
anyone who was elected in New York City
in New York State more than any governor
more than any mayor more than really
than any mayor or governor combined and
he held this power for 48 years almost
half a century so I felt if I could find
out where he got this power I had no
idea where he got it and really neither
did anybody else at the time I started
not only was there no book on public
authorities as a source of political
power
it wasn't even as I recall a magazine
article that examined that in any depth
but I felt if I could find out and show
the basis of Moses's power I would be
showing what urban political power power
and cities consisted of not in theory
but in reality not what the trappings of
power are but it's raw naked essence
after Robert Moses I wanted to try to do
the same thing with national political
power through Lyndon Johnson what first
caught my interest about Lyndon Johnson
were his six years 1955 through the end
of 1960 in which he was majority leader
of the United States Senate and what
court because just as Robert Moses had
done something that no one else had done
what caught my eye about those years
when Lyndon Johnson is those six years
were basically the only time since the
days of Webster clay and Calhoun that
the Senate of the United States really
worked in the way the founding fathers
had intended by which I mean as its own
center of governmental energy and create
to create creativity and ingenuity and
when he became leader the theory way the
theory was a collegiate have said so
often it was a cliche was that no one
could lead the Senate one of Johnson's
predecessors said no one can lead these
senators I have nothing to promise them
I have nothing to threaten them with but
Johnson did lead the Senate he
controlled it and he
so I felt that if I could find out how
he did that how he made it work that
would be a way of understanding
legislative power not in theory but in
reality in this country we think of
national power political power even if
it's not set it on the laws every
article in the newspapers in the
magazines
we think of national political power in
terms of executive power presidential
power but of course that's not what the
Founding Fathers intended if we just
think how in the Constitution they gave
Congress such great powers it hardly
needs saying that that's not even the
reality either since just because the
president proposes something it doesn't
become a law until Congress passes it
when I first thought of Johnson's Senate
years however and what I wanted to do
with them what I had in mind was
something much shorter than would
finally emerged and that is important
because not long after I began working
on the book I realized that it had to be
about something in addition to Lyndon
Johnson and in addition to legislative
power
I still remember quite clearly the
moment at which that happened I had been
doing what I always do at the store out
of a book trying to get a sense of the
place that I'm writing about its moods
and its mores its rituals and
intricacies just trying to get a feel
for it really so what I was doing was I
was spending a lot of time in the Senate
historical office where the historian
and associate historian dick Baker and
Don Richie was so helpful to me in
reading about the center I was sitting
up in the gallery hour after hour you
know that the tourists the groups of
tourists come in for 10 minutes and
leave when there's a big moment in a
debate or the reporters pour in and they
soon leave but I would sit there all day
looking down at the Senate sometimes I
felt that the Senate of the United
States was putting on a show just for me
and I would watch it on c-span of course
and a kind of home and I don't know what
you think of the way the Senate looks
from the gallery or on c-span but to me
it was really not very impressive
then the the chamber was still gloomy it
hadn't been a blue backdrop than you
know lit out the way it is for today if
it for television the desk seemed to me
very small too small really for the man
who was standing at them they seem sort
of spindly like the desks of a
schoolhouse to me the Senate looked a
little silly but the one place I had
never been during this time was actually
down on the floor of the Senate
it was hard then for an outsider to get
a pass to go down on the floor and I
remember the day that I finally got my
pass and I walked and I remember I
walked in the door on the left and down
the steps to the well of the Senate
Senate was not in session I was sort of
all alone on the floor I was very gloomy
when I got down to the well I turned
around and for the first time I looked
at the desks of the Senate the desks you
know are arranged in four long semi
circles arcs really around the well and
the four rows rise one behind the other
in tears and while individually from
above the desks may look silly from the
well that's not what they look like at
all from the well the tops of all the
desks in each row blend together so what
you are seeing or forlorn Hawks
gray talks of a rich mahogany that's
polished so highly every day that they
gleam in the lights in the ceiling far
above so when I was standing in the well
those four Leeming glowing or stretched
around me and stretched away from me
powerful and majestic in the gloom and
suddenly I had a thought which I hadn't
had before Daniel Webster stood at one
of those desks now I had known that
before of course I'd read that in a
thousand books in fact I had once done a
paper on Daniel Webster when I was at
Princeton
but suddenly in that moment whatever the
reason I can't really recreate the
process in one
and suddenly that fact that Webster
stood at a desk was an academic to me
anymore and I remembered what I had once
known what I had read how when he spoke
in the Senate Webster's hand always
rested flat on the desk when he spoke
now we never moved as he was giving an
address that's how he stood while for 30
years he fought to preserve the Union
black Dan Webster with his jutting black
eyebrows and his jet-black hair
Webster whose voice Ralph Waldo Emerson
wrote could shake the world
Emerson called Webster you know a great
cannon loaded to the lips for liberty
and I remembered how he always stood
there a hand on the desk in Mobile and I
thought about a lot of things that had
not really come together in my mind
and what I thought was solidified the
next day or the day after that I don't
remember when I got back to New York
because I live on Central Park West on
69th Street so when I jog I go into the
park at 69th Street and turn left and
run up toward the reservoir to run
around it and almost the first thing you
pass at 72nd Street is this great bronze
statue of Daniel Webster and engraved on
the pedestal of that statue are the
words liberty and union now and forever
one and inseparable now we all know that
speech
it's called Webster's reply to hane
Webster second reply to hang when we
read it in the history books January 26
1830s and wrote that no speech in the
English language perhaps no speech in
modern times had ever been is widely
distributed and widely read as Webster's
second replied to Haines
it made the union part of the religion
of this people you know I had it was
reprinted addition followed edition in
the western states it was passed from
hand to hand
and in Tennessee it was said that each
copy was read by 50 people and those
last great knowing words liberty and
union now and forever one and
inseparable
those last knowing words would be
memorized by generations of school
children they would be chiseled in
marble on walls and monuments those
words that were spoken in the Senate
among those desks of the Senate webster
clay and Calhoun Henry Clay of course he
didn't stand still when he walked he
strode back and forth among the desks up
and down the aisles flourishing this
handkerchief taking sniffs of snuff you
know he was talk about great speakers
when clay was young and was a lawyer in
Kentucky they said he could he could
hypnotize a jury once went on a speaking
to a national speaking tour for the whip
Whig party and so many people came to
see him that someone wrote that he
depopulated the fields and forests of
the West in Washington he was so
charming at a dinner party that we said
the white gloves of the hostesses that
Henry Clay kissed became treasured room
that memento is that they kept until
they died and and clay used to chew on
the Senate the same way there's a
description of him stepping gracefully
forward and back and from side to side
flourishing that handkerchief whenever
he wanted to emphasize he always carried
the snuff box and every wanted emphasize
a point he tapped the snuff box for
emphasis tall slender and graceful
calhoun of course they said he strode
between those desks like a caged loin
now this is the great triumvirate
for 30 years they fought to save the
Union now you could say in the event
they failed because the Civil War came
but you could also say and I believe
that this is true that by the
compromises the compromise of 1832
compromise of 1850 the Missouri
companies by the compromises that they
worked out they bought times 30 years of
time for the Union and during that time
the Union which had been an infant Union
grew strong enough so that when a war
came it could survive it and come back
together again
as a great nation these men these men
who saved the Union they weren't
presidents they were senators during the
19th century there were a lot of
glorious moments for the Senate but in
the 20th century of course that changed
and the moments that we remember them
and in the 20th century include Henry
Cabot Lodge he commanded from a desk in
the Senate when the Senate killed the
Treaty of Versailles in the League of
Nations dealt such a blow to the hopes
for peace in the world we remember the
isolationists who kept Roosevelt every
time Roosevelt tried to mobilize the
country to get it ready for war they
stood in his way then we remember the
south as committee chairmen that
controlled it for decades and for
decades made the Senate a damn against
which old liberal legislation broke in
vain so the Senate didn't work again
after webster clay in calhoun for a
hundred years until lyndon johnson
became majority leader and I realized in
those moments say after that first time
I was down on the floor of the Senate
that if I was truly trying to examine
the roots of legislative power
senatorial power for the purposes of
this book I had to try to show the
Senate actually exercising its power and
then losing its power I would have to
try to find out why at lost power and
the consequences for America of the fact
that it lost it the Senate was created
to do great things for a while it did
great things then that stopped why why
did the Senate stop working and how did
Lyndon Johnson make it work again if I
wanted to show the realities of
legislative power I had to answer those
questions in this book if I wanted to
show Lyndon Johnson getting power over
it transforming it I had to make the
readers see what he was transforming it
from and while I didn't think of it all
in that moment or to be honest I'm sure
in the next days or even weeks in that
moment I think I knew that this book was
not
gonna be just about Lyndon Johnson and
not just about legislative power but
about the Senate of the United States
the history of the Senate and what the
founding fathers intended it to be when
they said that each state should be
equal and sovereign within it and have
the same number of senators when they
said that the Senate should be able to
have enough power to stand even against
a popular and powerful president that's
why the terms of a senator a longer than
a president when they said that it
should be able to stand against the wave
of public opinion because that always
changes that's why only one-third of the
Senate can be elected at any one
election so that public opinion can
never get at 2/3 of a Senate at a single
at a single time when they really left
out any provision for some in the
Constitution for anyone to lead the
Senate because why would the Senators of
sovereign states want to be led a leader
you know in the Senate a majority leader
of Manara leaders I don't have to tell
this audience is a leader not of the
Senate but only of a party so how did
Lyndon Johnson rise to power in the
Senate and how did he lead it well
nothing was more remarkable than Lyndon
Johnson's rise you know in those days
today we talk about seniority but in the
night in 1949 when Johnson came
seniority was a much more all pervasive
thing didn't just rule on Capitol Hill
it ruled at dinner parties if you were a
hostess in Washington you were a dinner
party with more than one senator you had
to seat them in order from you in order
of seniority the questioning in the
closed committee rooms behind closed
doors would go in strict order seniority
the senior Democrats in majority party
member would finish doing his questions
then it would go across to the senior
member of the other party then back to
the second Democratic cetera
seniority dominated a lot of things and
of course then even more than now you
weren't supposed to rise on the floor of
the Senate very much in your first two
years at the end of his first two years
in the Senate
Johnson was the assistant leader of the
Democratic Party the end of four years
in January 1953 he is elected leader of
his party
he's only 44 years old I was going to
look up before I walked in here today to
see who the next youngest leader was and
what the average age of the leaders
before that was but I think the average
age was something like 62 so Johnson was
not only the youngest leader in history
but the youngest by quite a bit so how
did he raw and then two years later of
course in 1955 the Democrats get to be
the majority and he becomes the majority
leader so it had when he became leader
had become a cliche to say as I said
that no one could lead the Senate I have
nothing to promise them I have nothing
to threaten them with so how did Lyndon
Johnson lead it well the best answer to
that is given not by me but by Lyndon
Johnson it's the epigraph the first
sentence in my book it's a quote from
Lyndon Johnson speaking about himself he
said I do understand power whatever else
may be said about me I know where to
look for it and I know how to use it
well Lyndon Johnson was right in that
self-assessment and in this book we see
him looking for power in places where
nobody had looked for it before we
starting the book there probably 20
different I try to explain 20 different
sources of power that he found and
created I'll take one tonight which is
he looked not just in the Senate but
across the Capitol in the House of
Representatives now in those days again
even more than today the House and the
Senate regarded themselves as rival and
maybe not more than today but they
regarded themselves then also as rival
bodies and there wasn't much cooperation
between them but Lyndon Johnson realized
that he had something that no other
senator had and that was the pate the
friendship indeed the love of Sam
Rayburn now Rayburn as most of us in
this room know
the Senate as a speaker and Majority
Leader for more than 27 years and he
ruled it absolutely I mean if we
remember Rayburn he was a short blocky
man with immense shoulders and huge arms
a man of great physical strength he had
this great completely bald red head
which he was always afraid glistened in
the television lights and made him look
foolish
he had a fearsome temper you know they
said when Rayburn walked through the
halls of the Capitol it was like waves
breaking on a stone people hurried to
get out of his way because everyone was
afraid they might say something
inadvertently which would get the mighty
Speaker angry at them he was also a man
it's hard really today to imagine that
there was ever a man like Sam raver in a
position of such power you know when he
died after all these years and power his
total estate totaled less than $15,000
he's a man of great honesty he would
walk through the halls and people would
run up to him and ask for this change in
this bill or this deal or this
assignment or whatever
someone once said he would make he would
agree would not agree someone once said
don't you need to make notes to remember
what you said and he said if you always
tell what you mean you don't have to
remember to make notes to remember what
you said so I came to appreciate Sam
Rayburn's power but I also came to
appreciate his loneliness
you know when Rayburn came to Washington
in 1921 he writes his sister back and
bottom that he spends every weekend
driving around Washington looking for a
house big enough to hold all his
children few years later when he still
hasn't married or had any children he
writes the same sister God would I would
give for a towheaded boy to take fishing
but Rayburn is never going to have a
family
he's a terribly shy man he can't stand
to make small talk he feels he can't
make small talk he once said whenever I
try to tell the joke I'm the joke he
hates to go to dinner parties generally
when people invite him he will go once
as a courtesy but he will never go
again with women he's especially show.i
he marries once the marriage only lasts
three weeks no one knows what happened I
certainly don't but he never marries
again so he never has a family and on
the weekends you know during the week if
you're the speaker the house and
universe everyone wants something from
you so you were you walk through the
corridors you're the center of
everybody's attention but on weekends
everybody else goes home to their family
Rayburn didn't have a family he lived in
an apartment up on Dupont Circle by
himself so on weekends what Sam Rayburn
would do which walked the streets around
the Capitol over and over again
with that great grim face of his set in
an unsmiling grim expression as if he
wanted to be alone as if he was daring
people to come up to him but of course
the young man who worked him well when I
interviewed them they were old men but
when at the time they were young men
they knew better and they would tell me
how sometimes on weekends the loneliness
would get too great for mr. Wrayburn and
he would telephone one of them and I
asked him to come down to his office
because he had something urgent for him
to do and the young man would sit there
and watch the speaker sit behind this
huge desk pulling open one drawer after
another looking for some excuse for
having called his assistant down now
when Lyndon Johnson comes to Mary's Lady
Bird and comes to Washington in 1934 is
a congressman's assistant they call that
a congressman's secretary then he and
Lady Bird take a small apartment and
very quickly Johnson invites Sam Rayburn
to come for dinner and Rayburn comes
because he had worked with Lyndon
Johnson's father in the Texas
Legislature and therefore he would come
but ordinarily he would never come back
again but at this very first dinner a
bond is struck up it's not struck up
first between Rayburn and Lyndon Johnson
it struck up first between Rayburn and
Lady Bird now those of you who have read
my first two volumes know that the Lady
Bird Johnson when she was young was very
different from the poised gracious
dignified first lady that we know today
she was terribly shy she once told me
that when she was in high school she's a
very good student in a senior year she
was afraid she was going to finish first
a second and if she finished first a
second should be valedictorian a
salutatorian and have to give a speech
she told me I pray that if I finished
first a second I would get smallpox
I wrote she would rather have the scar
doesn't have to speak in public when
Johnson runs for Congress for the first
time not only can she not speak for him
I'll just went on for four years not
only can she not speak in public for
Lyndon Johnson but she can even be the
hostess at receptions in Texas they call
them coffees that's like when a woman in
the district has a reception in the late
afternoon for the for the women in the
area so they could come and meet the
candidates wife and one of these women
told me to watch Lady Bird Johnson stand
in a receiving line I had a coffee
without smile carved on her face as if
it was set in stone was the most painful
thing I have a sore and at the very
first dinner this paternal bond love if
you will from Sam Rayburn comes to
encompass Lady Bird so when Lyndon
Johnson invites Rayburn back he comes
and soon he's coming every Sunday not
for dinner but for breakfast Lady Bird
makes the food that this speaker likes
very hot Texas chili cornbread the way
he likes it homemade peach ice cream and
she says they have to breakfast I would
clear away and Lyndon and mr. Sam would
read the Sunday papers and the bond
comes to extend ray barons fondness
comes to extend not just over
Lady Bird but over Lyndon Johnson in
that same year 1934 Lady Bird is back
visiting her father in Marshall Texas
and Lyndon Johnson gets pneumonia which
of course in 1934 was very serious Sam
Rayburn sits beside Linden's bed in the
hospital all night and a straight-backed
wooden chair now we didn't know that
smoking was bad for you Henry
with a chain smoker and he smokes all
that night but he's so afraid that if he
gets up he might to brush the ashes away
he might disturb Linden that he doesn't
move and when Lyndon Johnson gets up in
the morning the first thing he sees is
the speaker sitting there with his vest
and lapels completely covered with
cigarette ashes and Johnson also
remembers that as soon as Sam Rayburn
sees that he's awake he leans over them
and says Lyndon never worried about
anything again if you need anything call
on me well Lyndon Johnson being Lyndon
Johnson it's not very long before he
does call on Sam Rayburn in a matter of
months or indeed even weeks what happens
Franklin Roosevelt creates a new New
Deal agency it's the National Youth
administration I there's going to be a
state director for each one of the 48
states and Lyndon Johnson wants to be
the director for Texas and there's no
reason in the world why anyone would
give him this job he's a congressman the
secretary is administrative experience
is zero why would anyone put him in
charge of an agency that's going to have
a budget of tens of millions of dollars
and hundreds of jobs there's a
remarkable passage in the memoirs of Tom
Connelly the old Texas senator who's
chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee and had enough power so that
Franklin Roosevelt had a deal with him
Connally writes something in his memoirs
an amazing thing happened yesterday
everybody knows that Sam Rayburn never
asks a man for a favor but yesterday Sam
came to my office and asked a favor and
would not leave until I did it the favor
was of course that Connally uses
influence to get Johnson the nya
director says Connally does so and
Johnson's career is on its way those of
you who have read my books also know
that the relationship was not only
smooth and 19th not always smooth in
1939 Johnson sees a way to get ahead
which involves betraying Rayburn
so he betrays him he thinks Rayburn is
never going to find out about it but of
course no one ever fools Sam
and he does know about it and for about
three years relationships are very very
cold but on Pearl Harbor died Lyndon
Johnson unless actually he reactivates
his Naval Reserve Commission and raver
and thinks he's going to fight in the
Pacific and as I wrote his heart melted
toward Lyndon in an instant as a
father's son melts towards a son when
the Sun is in danger on the day Lyndon
Johnson leaves for the west coast
he writes Sam Rayburn a one-page note
Rayburn folds it up very small and puts
it in his wallet when he dies 21 years
later and his executives have to
inventory the contents of that wallet
that note is still there he carried it
all his life so when Johnson gets to the
Senate in January 1949 this is a
political genius and he realizes an
incident that he has a source of power
that no one else has it's not enough for
a senator to get something passed in the
Senate let's say your constituents
demand you get a dam built well just
because the Saturday authorizes the dam
that's not enough it has to be
authorized by the house let's say you
get legislation passed in the Senate but
the house can change it then it has to
go to conference and it's a mess I know
and Oh Johnson realizes he's the only
senator who can go to the speaker who
rules the house and ask him to do a
specific thing for a senator and when
and you see this realization you can if
you down in the Johnson Lord when you're
reading through the memos and letters in
in Johnson's papers you see this
realization come over senior powerful
senators committee chairmen almost
immediately after his arrival Lyndon I
need my Dan billow authorized in the
house could you put a word in the
speaker's ear or Lyndon I don't like
what House Ways and Means did to my
appropriations bill could you have a
word with mr. Sammon Johnson of course
whenever he does such a favor make sure
that the senator knows it knows he owes
him a favor
and it also knows that he's gonna need
him again for similar favors that's a
real source of power trying to think of
something else I could say in one
paragraph that was another one of these
20 or whatever sources of power its cash
campaign
we have a political genius here he sees
in an instant that he possesses
something else that no other senator
possesses he is the only senator who
knows two different groups of people to
Texas natural gas and oil barons who
really need political influence in
Washington and are willing to pay in the
form of campaign contributions to get it
and all the liberal senators and
congressmen from the north who need
campaign contributions that don't know
the Texans Johnson makes sure that he is
the conduit for this money he makes sure
that all the Texas Barons contribute
only through him and he gives out the
money himself if there's one scene that
sums up this up what he did with it it's
a 1952 Johnson isn't running for office
but a lot of other senators are
Johnson's giving out campaign
contributions his lawyer walks into that
big living room in the perdón alleys he
sees Lyndon Johnson sitting there was
not one but two telephones up to his ear
and he's saying I've got 20 for him and
20 for him and 40 for him that's real
power and Lyndon Johnson used these
powers with a ruthlessness that made
them even more effective here is another
quote from Lyndon Johnson this is a
quote from Lyndon Johnson speaking about
himself I'm just like a fox I can see
the jugular and any man and go for it
but I always keep myself in rain I keep
myself on a leash just like you would an
animal well and that self assessment
Lyndon Johnson is only being partially
honest there are more than a few
examples in this book of how he let
himself fall off the leash you know his
very first months in the Senate in March
1949 I think in fact he left he seized
the jugular and the man and destroys him
with what he sees the man's name was
Leland doles he was chairman of the
federal Power Commission he was an old
idealistic new dealer he it's to his
field was public power power from
hydroelectric power from rivers and dams
power from natural gas etc he made
himself a great expert in that field he
believed as Franklin Roosevelt believed
that companies are entitled to profits
when they control a natural resource but
they're not entitled to gouge the public
wouldnot ballistic just because they
monopolize it with with too high prices
because as someone wrote who owns a
river if not the people
Roosevelt believes the same way when
he's governor of New York he makes
Leland the old chairman of the New York
State Power Authority when he comes to
Washington he brings oles to Washington
as chairman of the federal Power
Commission
oles has served two five-year terms now
it's 1949 and he needs it to be
renominated President Truman has renewed
them because Truman thinks as highly of
him as Roosevelt did and giant and
Johnson's campaign citizen in 1948 when
he's elected to the Senate he's very
largely financed by these natural gas
and oil men of Texas and his first
assignment from them is to defeat Leland
olds as reen AMA nation now that seemed
because lolz is preventing them from the
truly extraordinary price increases that
they wanted to put into place now it
seems like this is an almost impossible
assignment because everybody liked
Leland dollars you know most of the
Senators had had to deal with him in
some matter involving their States over
the 10 years he had been there and they
really had gotten even the most
conservative senators admired and
respected him but Johnson thorns' olds
is jugular he learns that back in the
1920s when those who's just recently out
of college he had worked as a reporter
for a wire service and The Associated
Press of course is a wire service today
you don't work for newspapers if you
work for The Associated Press you work
for The Associated Press you write a
story and whatever subscribing newspaper
subscribes to the Associated Press is
entitled to print your story and should
they want to print your byline on top of
it oles worked for a wire service called
the federated press it had 80 clients 79
of them were mainstream newspapers but
one was
the Communist Daily Worker Lyndon
Johnson has his assistants go through
every copy of The Daily Worker during
the 1920s looking for the byline by Lee
lanolin's he finds 54 instances in which
the byline appears in the Daily Worker
Lyndon Johnson has those 54 pages foetus
tattered and bound together so they make
a very impressive bundle takes it around
two senators and their offices and
convinces him that Leland doll has
really worked for the Daily Worker and
was really a communist then he holds a
series of hearings he makes himself he
gets the chairmanship of the
subcommittee that's holding the hearings
and old history nomination and using
these articles he really destroys holes
with an olds of course is helpless to
defend himself against the
cross-examination why did you write this
if you were in a communist because he
doesn't even remember these articles he
hasn't seen him for 25 years in war he
hadn't thought he had to do any
preparation for the hearings because
Johnson had told him they would just be
pro forma and then Johnson gives a
speech on the floor of the center in
which the crucial line on the note on
about Leland olds is what do we want a
commissioner or a commissar so olders
nomination is defeated in fact olds
isn't just a feeder he's destroyed he's
58 years old when this happens he's been
a civil servant all his life and he has
very modest savings I can never again
get a decent government job of course he
can't even get a decent job with one of
the companies in the field that he's
devoted his life to because when what
company would dare the hire a man who
was a communist he lives he lives the
rest of his life basically is a very
poor man and poverty was not the worst
of it
his wife Mord really can't believe that
the women that she as to what were her
friends in the little neighborhood in
wash
and Wharf McKinley Street where they
live that she'd had been her friends for
so long wouldn't talk to her anymore
when they saw her in the street because
they either they didn't want they were
afraid to talk to someone who had been
branded as a communist and the rest of
her life is really a story of one
nervous breakdown after another of all
the unpleasant things and there are a
lot of unpleasant things when you write
about Lyndon Johnson that you learn I
know what the worst moment learning
about something was for me in this book
it's a moment that occurs outside the
door of the subcommittee room where
Johnson has just destroyed all through
this course examination it's a recess
the Leland olds is standing in the
corridor sort of stunned he knows he's
been destroyed with his wife and one
young assistant and Lyndon Johnson comes
out puts his arm around Leland olds his
shoulder and says Lee we're still
friends aren't we there's nothing
personal in this you know it's just
politics
well that was politics Lyndon Johnson's
style of politics and it was very
effective
after that olds incident a lot of senior
senators were a little wary of Lyndon
Johnson a little afraid of this freshman
senators and of course fear creates more
power as leader we see the same
ruthlessness even man in Washington who
thought they were had seen everything in
Washington and thought they knew how
pragmatic politics could be sewer there
was something special about Lyndon
Johnson these senators scoop Jackson who
worked with Lyndon Johnson for 25 years
both in the Senate and before that in
the house once was trying to explain the
difference between President Kennedy and
President Johnson and this is what he
Jackson wrote Kennedy quote this is his
quote would explain precisely why a bill
was so important and why he needed the
Senators support but if the senator said
his constituency simply wouldn't let him
vote that way Jackson said Kennedy would
finally say he was sorry they couldn't
agree but he understood Lyndon Johnson's
scoop Jackson would say quote Lyndon
Johnson would
understand he would refuse to understand
he would
these are Jackson's words he would charm
you or knock your block off or bribe you
will threaten you anything he had to to
get you a vote and he'd get it that was
the difference he'd get it so when
Lyndon Johnson becomes leader he has the
powers he has found and created and the
ruthlessness with which he used them and
during the six years 1955 through the
end of 1960 that he was Majority Leader
the Senate was really run by Lyndon
Johnson led by Lyndon Johnson he really
ran it you'd see an hour senator would
come in and he was all up it's a huge
man six foot four with arms that with
long even for that height in the huge
hands be all up and down the oils back
and forth among the desk his eyes seemed
to miss nothing a senator would come in
sit down on a couch in the back of the
chamber for a moment's relaxation
johnson would be up there to the couch
he'd throw himself down we saw him put
the big arm around the shoulder grab
this lapel with the other hand lean that
face in and start charming and telling
these wonderful stories asking for what
he wanted you'd see another senator come
in across the hall across the floor he'd
be up backing him up against the wall
pinning him against the wall while he
collected his always missed nothing he
would see the doors to the swinging
doors to the Republican cloakroom liked
to swing open for a moment in that
moment Johnson would see that there was
a Republican senator who's voting Eden
don't forget during these six years
Johnson was usually operating with the
one vote margin forty-eight Democrats 47
Republicans and Wayne Morse the
independent he'd see a Republican
senator whose vote he needed and who was
though he thought he had on the next
bill to walking in a suspiciously
friendly way with one of President
Eisenhower's Republican White House
liaison men did he still have that vote
he'd hurry up and stand casually outside
the door the cloakroom said when the
senator came out he could find out if he
had that vote or whether he needed
another one in my book I described
Lyndon Johnson in the moments before a
vote on a major but relatively
we'll bill with the vote all but upon
him now he seemed always to be in motion
and the motion would be faster almost
frenzied as he talked the Senators his
hands never stopped moving gesturing
expressively chopping the air with a
snake killing gesture opening a palm to
illustrate a point punching the air with
the fist jabbing a lapel with a finger
patting a senator's shoulder
straightening his tie grabbing his lapel
hugging him if he agreed to the
proposition being made if he dropped
back down into his own front row Senate
share he might scroll down and it's
stretching out both legs across the
aisle will lean far back crossing them
but he wouldn't stay in any pose long
crossing and uncrossing his legs leaning
back in his chair with a hand up to his
face as he whispered to Richard Russell
close behind him were to a senator who
had approached with information or
inquiry pulling out a tally sheet
writing something on it tucking it back
in his pocket he seemed simply unable to
sit still for a moment abruptly
galvanized by a sudden thought he would
leap out of his seat going from slouched
to almost frenetic in an instant rush
over to a senator you'd see him with the
finger right in the face
he'd be over on the Republican side as
much as the Democratic then he'd be back
across the room pulling someone else off
to the side a slash of vivid movement
through the senatorial still life and
that was on an uncontroversial
relatively minor bet on a bill on which
the vote was going to be close and the
result of genuine political significance
the frenzy of Lyndon Johnson's actions
escalated another notch as the moment
approached for the roll call the call
that would determine the actual
irrevocable winning or losing for this
man who had to win Lyndon Johnson's
orders grew sharper more punctuated with
Shore he did things that you simply
couldn't believe you read you Burt
Humphreys oral history tell us about how
Lyndon Johnson kicked him in the shin
one day when he wasn't moving fast
on the Senate floor and when he still
didn't move fast enough Johnson kicked
him in the other should not have to say
although that is there in you Bert
Humphries oral history I didn't believe
it I thought he must be exaggerating and
I wasn't going to put it in my book
until him going through the newspapers
day day by day and there was a column by
the 'kathy columnist who's Robert S
Allen and he wrote at the time quote I
saw what Humphrey must be exaggerating
until he added look and he pulled up his
trouser leg and sure enough he had some
scars there then he pulled up the other
leg he had a couple of scars on his
shins we're linden had kicked him and
said get going now he wants you know you
talk about what he did with lapels he
wants back John fast story do we
remember John past story the smallest
senator from the smallest state Rhode
Island he was at the minute of man
Johnson once backed them up when my
story wouldn't give him a vote it's very
independent backed them across the
senator floor until he was up against
Bayes back was up against the wall of
the Senate couldn't move anymore then
Johnson leans over takes one of past
stories lapels in each hand and lifts
him up on his toes and holds him there
while he delivers the argument you know
it's a clear I'm wearing the wrong suit
you you we talk about the things that he
did say cliche to say that he grabbed
lapels a little but he did one thing
which you don't see written about in
those days many suits had button holes
in the lapels of Johnson thought he was
talking we're going to might pull away
even if he had really felt he would
stick his forefinger through but no so
the guy couldn't leave without leaving
his jacket behind then all of a sudden
he has enough votes but the goodness one
vote margin if nothing changes he's
going to win he doesn't want anything to
change he wants to control call to be
really fast but let's and then he he
will make the and worried let's say he
it's time for a roll call and he's still
a voter too short and his men are
working on someone in the cloakroom or
the Capitol Police are racing a senator
across Washington from his apartment to
the floor he directs the page he does
something that has never been seen
before were sent no sense in the center
he directs the pace of the voting with
his own hands he stands at that
front-row Center desk where it's an
advance in the Senate is a really love
Johnson so tall but as he stands and his
eyes are almost of the eyes of the
presiding officer if he wants the vote
to go fast he goes like this like auto
mechanic revving up a motor or conductor
if he wants the votes to go slow if he
needs one or two votes you go is this
like this and they call the vote very
very slowly as senators hurried into the
chamber for the vote many walk down to
the well to work with their colleagues
standing at the edge of the well
towering over the men in it Lyndon
Johnson would raise his long arm over
them making those big circles like an
orchestra conductor leading the United
States Senate that Senate that for so
long had refused to be led sometimes he
would indulge in an even more blatant
manifestation of his power so child that
sometimes the vote wouldn't have gone
exactly as he as he thought and he was
one vote short to PT reporters and the
gallery would watch him he change votes
right on the floor he'd walk over to a
senator the reporters would see and bend
over they'd see this big smile this
charming smile on his face but then if
the senator didn't respond they'd see
Johnson's face change that four finger
Jay about they see the Senators face
changes the threat was pounded in and
then the senator would get up and asked
tell the clerk he had been incorrectly
recorded
sometimes Johnson wouldn't even bother
to walk across the floor once he yelled
across the well to Allen freer the
senator from Delaware who's sitting in
his desk
change your vote Allen the senator from
Delaware did not immediately respond so
Johnson yelled again in a shout heard in
the words of one writer by more than 80
senators and the galleries change your
vote Allen Allen changed his vote you
psy.d wrote a wonderful description of
Lyndon Johnson he wrote of this tall man
with his mind attuned to every sight and
sound and parliamentary nuance he
signaled the roll calls faster or slower
he gave another signal in the door would
open and more guys would run in my god
running the world power enveloped him
and what did Lyndon Johnson do with this
power so those of you who have read the
book or I hope will know he broke the
dam that the Senate had been for so many
decades against liberal legislation he
passed things that no one believed could
be passed in the Senate the first
edition of disability benefits the
Social Security expansion of Social
Security benefits that tens of millions
of people hadn't uncovered the
beginnings of what we now call Medicare
or Medicaid and of course the thing that
I devote most time in the book to
passing the first civil rights bill in
1957 the first civil rights bill since
reconstruction the first civil rights
bill in 82 years started this lecture by
saying I realized I had to talk about
legislative power you watch Lyndon
Johnson pass this bill if you're
interested in political power you say
this bill could never be passed no one
can get this bill passed
I know dick Becker and Don rich you know
the exact number was another thing I
didn't look up today but I think in 1957
of the 14 Standing Committees of the
Senate if I'm ruined by one or two
southerners were chairmen of nine
including almost all of the most
powerful committees they had the power
in the Senate they determined of course
that no civil rights bill is going to
pass since reconstruction hundreds of
bills have been introduced thousands
scores of them have passed
the House of Representatives not one has
passed the center Johnson sets out to
pass this bill to watch him do it to get
these votes together one by one you can
say he puts these votes together is to
see not just legislative power but
legislative genius
and therefore the book would have to be
not just the history of the Senate not
just the biography of Lyndon Johnson not
just a study of legislative power but a
study of legislative genius the life of
Lyndon Johnson is to me a very poignant
life the story of his boyhood is just
sad poignant and so was a lot of the
rest of his life but his time in the
Senate was not saying which makes that
in a way the most poignant thing of all
because he wasn't content to stay there
Wood wanted something else which he got
Lady Bird Johnson would write in her
diary those 12 years in the Senate were
the happiest 12 years of our lives and
they were Lyndon Johnson was born to be
there the Senate with his home and for
the United States they were productive
years when you look back at the Senate
of the United States during the first
two and a quarter centuries of its
existence of the Republic's existence
after the days of Webster clay and
Calhoun the Senate worked really only
during one period that six-year period
in 1955 through 1960 in which Lyndon
Johnson was its leader it really worked
then Lyndon Johnson was indeed what I
call him master of the Senate thank you
ographers well that was wonderful Bob
bob has agreed to take a few questions
we have a bit of a dilemma we're also
going to have a book signing when this
follows so we do have time however for a
few questions Bob yes sir
how Johnson was able to make chain could
you all hear that question in 1959 there
have been major changes in the
filibuster rules do I have any insights
into how Johnson was able to do that I
don't actually remember that change
specifically but the way he got rules
changed and got a lot of changes done in
the Senate techniques was simply by the
fact that the southern senators trusted
him they also wanted to raise him to the
presidency Richard Russell - what that
was his first priority to get a
southerner Lyndon Johnson so they would
allow him to do things that they would
never allow someone else to do as leader
yes yes do you have any opinion about
how you could sum up with difference
between President Johnson and President
Nixon no no IIIi I'd have to really
think about that and I haven't I'm sorry
yes sir
I read an article in the April 1st issue
of the 2002 New Yorker that I have here
April 1st and it depicts up Lyndon
Johnson being a Titanic figure over
Robert Parker a patron a patron of his
who voted for him and his and his name
Robert Parker appears on at the bottom
here yeah and you have excerpts from his
book yeah
Capitol Hill in black and white I can't
buy the sale there's three pages in your
book of Capitol Hill black and white
since we're you're paraphrasing quote so
my question is and light of fair use is
illegal to use another's author's work
without express permission you know
other than educational for commercial
use you mentioned in April 2002 on book
TV that you did not meet him but his
name appears in the index and you had
three pages of quotes and paraphrases in
your book sir
I like for you to meet Robert Parker the
first black major dear to sitting down
oh man right here
an answer to your question which is a
very insulting question nobody's ever
accused me of plagiarism before you so
let me explain - we don't interrupt me
okay let me answer that since you just
accused me something which I can say
really love you're allowed to use
anything as long as you give them full
credit I don't think there's a single
quote in there that I don't say mr.
Parker said from mr. Parker's book you
say I play did you have permission it's
a quote and put it in your book I just
said you plagiarize I said your
paraphrase and they have quotes and we
have his name in the index of your book
under the compassion of Lyndon Johnson
the territory of Hawaii which was a
territory until became his state in 1959
and I think the Dixiecrats did not want
to become a state because that's two
more senators I think didn't quite
himself but the question is about the
territory of Hawaii before became a
state in 1959 yes the Dixiecrats did not
want Hawaii to become a state because
that would give it two more senators yes
so clearly Johnson then must have done
some arm-twisting to persuade the Senate
to make Hawaii State and have two more
Democrat senators yes actually was
linked with the admission of Alaska so
that they felt they'd have two votes on
on either side yes sorry in the trilogy
so far just keep getting better and
better in the last I enjoyed the
description of Johnson as a technician
politician more than the history of the
Senate but it was a marvelous marvelous
book you've almost set yourself up for a
failure for the next one
it seems it would be hard to to exceed
but I'm compelled to ask you presume and
you are going to write the presidential
years would you be willing to tell us
how you plan to frame that that next
book because if you could write a
history of the presidency it would be
something to behold I'm not sure that's
possible well that's a really good
question I'm actually trying to figure
that out now I can tell you something
that I want to do because when you look
at Lyndon Johnson's presidency you
really said what are the great things I
mean the Great Society in particular
civil rights legislation which I know I
feel we might not even have today we
might not have today if it wasn't for
Lyndon Johnson and on the other side
Vietnam in all my books I try to show
the effect of power on the powerless to
show the effect of power on people for
good or ill that's why I'm interested in
writing about political power so what
I'm going to do my wife and I were going
to try to find the southern city we're
gonna try to live there for long enough
to see what effect really has Lyndon
Johnson's civil rights legislation had
on the lives of black Americans do they
have better schools now because he got
them to vote for example are they less
afraid of the sheriff when they see him
driving down the street because they can
vote them out of office
and on the other side I don't quite know
how I'm going to do it yet but I want to
go to Vietnam
einar and I will go to in Vietnam and I
want to show where to really means when
I made you industrialized nation makes
war on what is basically a third world
country though if you can say I don't
know how the book is going to be framed
but those are going to be the two big
concerns Ted one from over here yes
Johnson took this previously powerless
position the majority leader of the
Senate actually the people who had
inhabited previously had been
embarrassed it was a good thing that
people flee and I'm I'm one and he
transformed it I'm wondering what your
perception is of what has happened to it
since you left well I don't I I I don't
know that I you know I don't it's tough
the one thing I learned is you don't
really know about anything unless you
research it for yourself so the the
dispute that's going on now I'm I'm not
gonna pretend that I know all about it I
don't think the Senate has worked since
Lyndon in the same way you know Johnson
created his own legislation I mean
Eisenhower would send up a bill you know
Johnson would have his people rewrite it
so completely for example this that was
his bill and then he would work together
he dealt with the president as an equal
you know it's really I it's really
striking in light of things today a
Bryce Harlow who is one of President
Eisenhower's aides you know with tell me
about how when Lyndon Johnson wanted to
negotiate with Eisenhower on something
that was really sticky when he came to
the White House he wouldn't come to the
front and it wouldn't come to the side
come to some exit where nobody could see
him and then he'd go up to eyes and how
his office and hollow was the only
person there a lot of times and he said
he took notes but he wouldn't show them
to me and I don't think anyone's ever
seen him and I said well what I said
well what did they talk like I said all
I can tell you is they were two big boys
you know and Johnson was not afraid in
light of I mean whether think I'm not
judging this as being a right or a wrong
but one of the big differences he was
not afraid to say to eisenhower and did
you were entire legislative program
nothing is going anywhere until I get
something that I want I take yes sir
better job using his power for the good
Robert Moses or Lyndon Johnson it's a
terrific question I don't know that I've
ever I've ever thought both of them
produced great good you know Moses of
course created things every time I go to
Jones Beach it's sort of reversed
because Moses started is this idealist
and dreamer who wanted to create parks
and did wonderful things and then as he
acquired power he changed into something
else and he started to have the real
arrogance and a complete lack of concern
for human beings and he would just
destroy neighborhoods by running
highways or even Johnson it's sort of
the opposite when I think of Johnson I
think you know we learn in college Lord
Acton's axiom all power corrupts
absolute power corrupts absolutely I'm
not so sure the more I think about power
that that's true what I think is with
that that's always true what I think is
always true what power always does is
reveal I think when you get power you
see what you wanted to do what a person
wanted to do all along because you have
the power to do it in this book I'm not
gonna spend it but you just see him when
he's 20 years old wanting to help those
Mexican American kids in Cotulla when he
gets to be President he says I didn't
ever know I have the power to help them
but I think he what he said is I tell
you one thing now that I have it I mean
to use it so one of the real things
about Lyndon Johnson's life you could
say is the cleansing or revealing
effective power of course with
everything in Johnson's life that's not
the whole story because at the end it's
not like Franklin Roosevelt's life when
you say what's the story of his
presidency getting the country through a
Great Depression and a Great War that's
the arc of Franklin Roosevelt's
presidency Lyndon Johnson's presidency
doesn't end that way so it's a
complicated story
yes sir
I wanted to ask you a question from your
fourth book in 1960 when at the
Democratic convention with John F
Kennedy Lyndon Johnson and a draft
effort for Adlai Stevenson
Kennedy didn't win till he got to
Wyoming and I know the Stevenson people
were trying to block Kennedy on the
first ballot and Clarence Cannon who was
a very close friend of Lyndon Johnson
told the Iowa and Kansas delegations
that they were locked in by state law
and suddenly cannon switched his he
switched his decision and said they
could vote any way they wanted some have
interpreted this to mean that Johnson
decided early on at the convention that
he wanted to be the vice president that
it wasn't right now what I'm doing down
in the lumen Johnson library is actually
looking through the papers on when he's
running against President Kennedy and
trying to talk to as many people who
were alive there what happened I've
talked to some before about that I don't
know anything about the incident so
there's that you mentioned but I it's a
very interesting race and I really want
to go into it in detail and I'm that's
what I'm doing learning about right
right now I suppose I could take two
more questions yes with all the power
that Lyndon Johnson had in the Senate
why did he give that up to be vice
president well that's a very complicated
question
you know Lyndon Johnson said when he was
asked this by reporters at the time
power is where power goes he thought he
was going to have power even
vice-president part of the reason just
to related to this is Sam Rayburn was
still the Speaker I but Rayburn of
course has cancer even as Johnson is
sworn in and soon dies partner I think
is a real miscalculation by Lyndon
Johnson about John Kennedy's toughness
and smallness but I will so that's the
stuff of learning about now I don't
pretend to know the answer to that how
about one more one more question yes sir
compliment
I think the question for those of you
couldn't hear it is about academic
historians and and me a juror or
journalistic historian I think it's a
real shame I think that theories I mean
I I lean on academic historians there's
a lot of wonderful thing I'm not
constantly turning to their books
they're one big difference and I think
it's a real thing that it's a shame that
it's not fully appreciated in my
academics is the importance of writing
you know would you call the time in
place a sense of place giving a sense of
so that you can see the scene you know
you just sometimes if you're a judge on
something you get a lot of books to read
and you can tell in three or four pages
if the guys to what the writing mattered
now I believe that a work of a
nonfiction if it is in the work of
nonfiction is to endure it had the prose
has to be at the same level as a work of
fiction that endures I have to say it's
not a widely shared thing but it's
something I believe but it's something
that I believe thank you very much
well have happened haven't we been
fortunate tonight this has just really
been a wonderful evening Bob and thank
you for giving so much of yourself now
we're going to have a book signing but
you're going to need to follow the rules
here because we I would like to move Bob
out to the book signing table it's next
to where you can buy books if you don't
have one and I'm going to ask that you
settle for a short inscription or a
signature or we may be here all night
let's give Bob Carol one more round of
applause thank you